a couple years ago i was able to raise
two million dollars for my startup
all because of a single tweet there are
plenty of entrepreneurs who can raise
money quickly because they already know
all of the big vcs
but this was cold outreach to an
investor that i'd never met before
but i knew this would work because i was
using a three-step framework that is
pretty much guaranteed to get you a
meeting with a vc
if executed properly fundraising is
often confusing and frustrating for
early-stage entrepreneurs
but it doesn't have to be follow the
steps outlined in this video
and you'll be having pitch meetings with
plenty of venture capitalists in no time
i've raised money 10 different times now
and even though each time was slightly
different
every successful fundraise follows this
same fundamental pattern
today i'm going to tell you how i raised
two million dollars for my company using
twitter
it's a pretty funny story actually
here's the tweet that brought in two
million dollars
if it looks underwhelming that's because
it was designed to be
a venture capitalist had tweeted about
some research that they were doing
and i simply replied saying that they
missed one important piece of the puzzle
and i could help them even though that
tweet is only 17 words
there's actually a lot going on there so
let's break it down and work through
what you need to do as an entrepreneur
to win the attention of venture
capitalists
everyone thinks that they need to be a
massive influencer in order to leverage
platforms like twitter to raise money
but that's just not true
most entrepreneurs are far too busy to
grow a serious following on social media
and in an odd twist growing a massive
following can actually hurt your
credibility
there's a great saying that goes the
rhetorical style of any twitter account
that continues to gain
followers converges on that of a fortune
cookie
and i've certainly seen this in practice
endless growth requires
endlessly broadening your appeal but
that leads to a kind of lowest common
denominator type of content that anyone
can understand
entrepreneurs need to be experts in
their fields and if you're working on
something truly new and disruptive
there's a good chance that the industry
is extremely small consider crypto at
the early stage
most of the conversation about bitcoin
was hosted on small forums and
completely inaccessible to general
audiences
you had to have strong software
engineering chops to even follow basic
discussions but that was actually a
positive signal to investors so instead
of becoming a fortune cookie account
and constantly tweeting variations of
work hard and anything's possible
i've always focused on talking about
complex topics
where i can actually push the
conversation forward even though those
tweets aren't likely to go
viral anytime soon at the time that i
posted that tweet
i barely had a thousand followers but
you could quickly skim my profile
and know that i had experience in
consumer startups and that was enough to
pass a quick
check by someone visiting my profile and
wondering is this person legit
so before you fundraise it's important
to really know your industry inside and
out
you don't need to be creating loads of
content but if you're going to use a
particular platform
it's good to establish a solid track
record and that's step one
become an expert and people will want to
hear what you have to say
there's a great saying that goes if you
want to be interesting
be interested when you're working on a
new idea
you should be voraciously consuming
information related to that idea
sometimes this means taking classes on
the subject but other times it's just
taking the time to read books
blog posts and technical papers to
really understand where the cutting edge
is
in your industry once you know your
industry code and are ready to start
networking with venture capitalists it's
important to focus on finding founder vc
fit
a lot of entrepreneurs get caught up
chasing celebrity investors
but that's actually a huge mistake for
two main reasons
the first is obvious famous investors
are flooded with pitches all day long
so it'll be hard to break through the
noise but the second reason
is actually more important here famous
investors who don't know about your
market
or aren't interested in it are less
likely to be helpful
it can be tempting to just look at the
midas list of top venture capitalists
and think
everyone on there would be an incredible
addition to your company but a vc who is
focused on biotech
may not be able to help at all with a
crypto project
and vice versa you need to focus on
finding investors who have specific
experience in your industry
look at who's funding companies that are
like yours and then start to follow and
engage with these folks instead of just
aiming for whoever has the biggest name
that's exactly what i did when i was
raising money i stumbled upon someone
who worked at graycroft partners
who was hyper focused on
direct-to-consumer e-commerce companies
his name was teddy citron and he had
only been in venture for a few years
he has a sharp eye for e-commerce
companies and new trends but he's not
exactly a household name in silicon
valley at least not yet
that didn't matter though because i was
focused on founder vc
fit not strictly big names and this is
step
two engage with investors who are
actually experts in your industry when
you find investors who are
active in your industry it can be
tempting to try and pitch them
immediately but coming on too strong can
often be a mistake
i always think of that scene in star
wars where han solo is flying past darth
vader's ship
don't get jittery luke there are a lot
of command chips keep your distance
though chewy but don't look like you're
trying to keep your distance
i don't know fly casual you don't want
to look desperate for funding
but you also don't want to look like
you're hiding the fact that you're
desperate for funding
just fly casual and start having actual
conversations with vcs about what's
going on in your industry so that's what
i did i started engaging with teddy on
twitter
first by reposting some research that
he'd done on the industry he had
essentially collected
every sub-sector of the
direct-to-consumer ecommerce space
and organized them into a massive google
sheet his post had done well on medium
and he certainly didn't need me to
signal boost it but this little shout
out
put me on his radar my tweet only got
three likes
but one of those was from him five weeks
later i followed up
by replying to his original post about
the spreadsheet saying
love this post there's one category you
missed though
happy to chat about it if you're
interested teddy had clearly spent hours
pouring over industry data
and he definitely thought that he had
considered every possible segment but i
knew that he had missed one critical
area
and it happened to be the industry that
i was currently trying to disrupt big
tobacco my co-founders and i
have been grinding on our new idea
called lucy for over a year at this
point and we knew a lot about the
tobacco industry
cigarettes kill millions every year but
the tobacco industry still generates
over one
trillion dollars per year a trillion
with a t
teddy had outlined dozens of micro
industries with market sizes as small as
four billion dollars
but he had completely missed tobacco
there was a good reason for this
no startups had really attacked big
tobacco before so there wasn't much buzz
in silicon valley about the opportunity
that was exactly why we liked the idea
so much
smoking was a huge problem and solving
it would clearly have a positive impact
while still being a good business
now i could have just said hey you
missed tobacco you should add that to
your sheet
but that strategy would have failed
building intrigue
is one of the most powerful
communication skills i try and do it in
every youtube video i make
first by getting you the viewer
interested in what i'm about to discuss
before diving into the details i knew
that anyone who had spent that much time
researching e-commerce companies
wouldn't be able to resist the
opportunity to learn about a new area
that they hadn't considered before
this is step three build intrigue around
what you're working on
so the investor wants to learn more
there's a reason why murder mysteries
are so popular
just open up netflix and you'll see
dozens of shows about mysteries
humans are hardwired to seek out answers
to unsolved questions
it's basic human psychology but i didn't
just leave him hanging
i offered a clear solution a way to make
his analysis more complete
and learn about the missing category
just chat with me
adding a clear call to action there is
critical venture capitalists get flooded
with requests for meetings all day long
and their schedules are packed with
back-to-back calls the easiest way to
get a meeting
is to offer something of value in return
setting time aside for a meeting creates
a cost
so you need to offset that with a
benefit every vc knows that most
meetings
won't result in a good deal these
meetings are risks that they take in
order to find the next great company as
an entrepreneur
you can offset that risk by guaranteeing
that they will learn something
interesting that they didn't know before
even if the investor winds up passing on
the deal
they leave knowing more than they did at
the start of the meeting
and that's valuable to someone whose job
it is to understand markets
my plan here worked perfectly i had
established myself as someone
knowledgeable in e-commerce
found an investor who was uniquely
interested in e-commerce
and then piqued their interest and
offered to help them expand their
understanding of e-commerce
following these three steps will make
cold outreach to investors way more
likely to succeed
investors get flooded with pitch decks
to their emails all day long
so you need to stand out building
relationships slowly and then leveraging
human psychology to ensure that you get
a meeting
is vastly superior to spamming investors
and hoping that they respond to you
when you start fundraising for your
business it's useful to think about the
process like a funnel
at the top of the funnel you have all
the investors who could possibly fund
your business
but you need to narrow that down to just
the investors who would be a good fit
once you have
that list you need to get meetings with
them it's impossible to get an
investment out of every single meeting
even incredible companies like facebook
and google had meetings where investors
passed on the opportunity to invest
so your job is to make sure that when
you reach out to an investor
they take the meeting following this
three-step plan will make sure that you
get those meetings
and don't waste your time reaching out
to dozens of investors who just ignore
you
now to be fair when i sent this tweet i
already had a pretty significant startup
experience under my belt
i'd co-founded soylent and raised over
75 million dollars for that business
but i really think that doesn't matter
all that much
when i was still in college i used the
exact same technique to get in touch
with jim brayer who had led the series a
in facebook and i'd seen giving a talk
at stanford alongside mark zuckerberg in
2012
brayer and his fund excel partners were
riding high off of the facebook
investment
but i was still able to chat with him on
twitter just by following his work
and sending him the occasional
thoughtful message it was super
inspiring at the time
and a big reason why i felt that
starting a company in silicon valley
would be a great move for me
so regardless of your background if you
can become a true
expert in your industry investors will
want to talk to you
it's really that simple so get out there
and start pitching but don't
look like you're pitching you know pitch
casually if you want to talk about
fundraising strategy for your startup
just leave me a comment below or dm me
on twitter and please check out this
recommended video
the youtube algorithm thinks that you'll
really like it